welcome everybody and thank you for
being here today
my name is project
and i lead product management for
dataplex at google cloud
and joining me today is john allen
head of data and analytics product
strategy at deutsche bank john has been
with deutsche bank for over nine years
building their data platforms and
enabling and championing big data and
data science within the organization
welcome john and thank you for your
partnership as well as for being here
today
to share deutsche bank's data journey
with us
well thanks for inviting me it's great
to be here with you today
likewise
um so let's get started
um let's take a look at the enterprise
data landscape which as many of you know
is diverse and becoming increasingly
distributed with data that is stored in
data lakes data warehouses specialized
data marks and databases
not only on gcp but on prem
as well as in other clouds
now each one of these systems have their
own way of handling metadata security
and governance
so
on one hand while the data is becoming
more distributed the number of users
within an organization that need access
self-service access to this data in the
tools of their choice is also growing
and as a result companies often find it
challenging to consistently manage and
govern their data while making this data
universally discoverable and accessible
to the data consumers
honestly it's an operational nightmare
that often results in data silos and
impacts the overall analytics agility of
most organizations
if you look at the data
67 percent of the data that is produced
is actually never analyzed
and 68 of the companies are unable to
realize any tangible measurable value
from their data
what is even more surprising
is that only 16 of the data consumers
that have access to data
actually trust the data that they have
access to
and this is exactly why we built
dataplex
an intelligent data fabric
that unifies your distributed data to
help automate data management
and power analytics at scale
so what does that actually mean so let's
double click
a little bit um dataplex is built from
ground up
for distributed data requiring you to
know to not move your data or duplicate
your data
at the foundation of dataplex is its
ability to logically represent data and
unify data from a metadata perspective
regardless of where this data is stored
we focused on three key areas of value
intelligent ai driven data management
centralized security and governance and
an integrated analytics experience
bringing together both gcp native and
open source tools
all of these areas are tightly
integrated in a task
centric experience helping you build a
flexible data platform and making this
data accessible to your end users
while ensuring that your policies and
best practices can be consistently
enforced
now this is a vision for dataplex we are
starting out by unifying the data that
our customers use for analytics on gcp
before extending it to other sources
outside of gcp
taking a closer look at that task
centric experience we've built an
experience that focuses on the
operations that you need to undertake on
your data on a daily basis
starting from curating
and managing that data to monitoring
securing analyzing this data
we have built key integrations with
existing products such as bigquery
data
proc google cloud
google cloud storage
uh data fusion data flow data catalog
and others to really bring together that
single pane of glass that you can use to
curate manage monitor secure and analyze
your data
with dataplex
you can really organize your data in a
way that is meaningful for your business
around different domains based on how
this data is produced and owned or how
this data is used instead of where this
data is stored
you can define standardized policies
around access control data quality data
classification and life cycle management
and you can leverage the built-in data
intelligence and metadata propagation
capabilities of dataplex to get out of
box access to this data from a variety
of tools both gcp native as well as open
source
we have a number of customers who have
been our early adopters
using dataplex and these customers range
or come from various different industry
verticals as well as geographies
and they're using dataplex
as that foundational component of the
data platform and seeing value
in having this unified data fabric to
manage and govern the distributed data
and today you know i'm
really happy to have john here with us
who is going to talk about
how
he sees the value of data in
the overall strategy at deutsche bank
his vision for
the data strategy
and the role that dataplex plays in
realizing that vision
so welcome john we are super excited to
have you here
um could you tell us a little bit more
about yourself first and then a little
bit more about deutsche bank and how you
use data today
sure well thanks again it's great to be
here so i work within deutsche bank's
chief data office
which is part of our technology and data
and innovation division
and our goal is really to enable the
secure supply
preparation and analysis of data across
the entire organization
now in my role looking at product
strategy i spend a lot of my time
working with the business teams and
technology vendors
to ensure that we have the right road
maps in place to deliver those
capabilities
deutsche bank is the leading german bank
we have 84 000 employees and operate
just under
1 900 branches with offices in over 50
countries
the bank comprises of four
client-centric divisions a corporate
bank a private bank an investment bank
and an asset manager dws which deutsche
bank maintains a significant stake in
now being a global bank we rely upon a
very complex global technology estate
comprising of tens of thousands of
machines thousands of applications and
hundreds of operational and analytical
data stores
our total data footprint is in excess of
100 petabytes
and we use that data for a wonderfully
diverse set of use cases
um trying to think of some in terms of
our some of the more interesting ones
our front office team use data to drive
real-time analysis and low-latency
algorithmic trading
and allows our product managers to
develop highly personalized client
offerings
in the middle and back office we
leverage big data processing to help
manage risk and to prevent fraud
and like any business we rely upon
highly accurate and timely financial
data to serve regulatory and financial
reporting requirements
um you know
it's you you operate in such a global
market and the complexities of
operations that you just mentioned
across different businesses within the
bank
is quite interesting
uh what role does data play at deutsche
bank and what has your journey with data
been like so far
well i agree i mean fundamentally we're
a data business and data is the digital
manifestation of our clients their
transactions and relationships and our
internal processes however we didn't
always view ourselves as a data business
instead we had a more
application-centric mindset which saw
data as more of a side effect of that
application processing we locked data
away in disparate silos with
inconsistent taxonomies and formats and
a lack of clear ownership and and an
over-reliance on bilateral
point-to-point data feeds
so to address this we established a
long-term plan our data strategy
to improve the availability of high
quality data
organized around a set of consistent
data models and golden sources
to uplift skills in data and increase
understanding of data problems across
the entire organization
and we set out to enable modern
analytics such as big data and machine
learning
the transformation took sustained
investments over many years
and was executed in an environment of
ever-changing regulations
just as an aside last year there were
over 6 000 pages of new rules that we
needed to examine to understand their
impact on that data landscape
today we are a much more data centric
organization which actively manages and
improves its data as part of the normal
day-to-day operations
we operate an integrated ecosystem of
analytics platforms and we have the key
trusted sources of high quality business
data needed to drive
intelligent decision making
i know you asked for successes and i
think frankly there are too many to
mention but from my personal perspective
i think the work the private bank has
done creating new personalized offerings
for our retail clients
through the application of machine
learning is especially cool
as is the big data processing that our
risk teams
use to allow us to be much more
efficient with our capital
it's quite interesting to hear how you
know you have made us this transition or
the bank has made this transition from
an application centric view to a data
centric view
in an industry that is so highly
regulated with as you just mentioned
changing uh regulations and compliance
rules
um so what have been your top learnings
and challenges so far
well for me some of the most significant
learnings relate to governance ownership
and how we as an organization think
about data our data culture if you will
foremost for me data needs to be treated
as a first-class citizen within the
enterprise if it is to be used and
reused effectively it must be seen as an
asset in its own right
also finding the right balance between
security and stability coupled with
agility to deliver analytics and help
customers is difficult
maintaining distinctly separate
operational and analytical organizations
fails to deliver analytical stability
and efficiency
what i mean there is this is this is
when those teams do not use
and thus value each other's rep
representations of what is innocence the
same data
metadata is also a critical
foundation for effective data management
and data governance
however building and maintaining a
unified repository of high quality
metadata is a significant challenge
in traditional i t environments
and finally
i think whilst centralization of data
can seem like an attractive approach to
achieving consistency and standards and
the application of policies it very
often leads to bottlenecks that inhibit
business agility
so given these learnings especially you
know learnings around how to build trust
in data how to avoid data duplication
how to put better data at the center and
and you know foundation of your data
platform
um could you share uh with us what is
your short-term and long-term uh data
strategy for the bank
yeah i'd love to um well our goal is to
democratize the use of data and
analytics
by making it a secure and frictionless
self-service experience
only then will we be able to make data
accessible to everyone and not just the
data experts within the organization
and we intend to do this by investing in
the automation of controls and policies
which along with high quality metadata
technical business and contextual
metadata will allow us to build a data
control plane that ensures that our data
is easy to find and access
yet always remains secure wherever it is
used
now currently we're completing our
transition to managing data as an asset
changing rit processes to allow data to
thrive outside of those owning
applications we traditionally had
we're also converging on common
approaches to data sharing and data
reuse which use streamlined data
governance processes
a new unified repository of metadata and
automation to make our data more
accessible
to help our engineering teams we're also
developing standard reference
architectures for common data problems
such as streaming and batch analytics
and machine learning in gcp
and finally we're investing in our
people with training in cloud and agile
data best practices
so you know speaking of cloud um and
your partnership with uh google cloud
how has google cloud helped you realize
your data vision
well the partnership with google has
given us a fantastic base to build our
future banking services on
technologies such as gcs bigquery data
flow data proc are much more powerful
and easy to use than our on-premise
equivalents
likewise cloud sql datasore gce app
engine and pubsub for transactional
systems
however for me what's really exciting is
the advancements in machine learning
that vertex ai and bigquery ml can bring
but that's not to say it's all plain
sailing there is still a lot of work to
integrate and assemble these products
into effective business solutions
and this is especially true in a
risk-averse highly regulated industry
such as ours speaking frankly there is
still quite a gap to close
i think this is an area where we see the
partnership being especially beneficial
so google understands this complexity
and together we are developing
approaches to solve these problems in
the cloud
in fact we are already seeing some
exciting product developments from
google
a good example of that is indeed
dataplex
uh you know your team uh has been an
early adopter of dataplex and your close
partnership is extremely valuable for us
as you provide us
uh you know product guidance on product
direction
i would love to hear more about how you
see dataplex fit in your overall data
strategy how dataplex is helping you
with some of the data challenges that
you mentioned early on
yeah absolutely well we are looking to
use dataplex to give us a way of
organizing our data
around our core business and data
concepts such as global markets
data payments data customer data without
having to copy that data from its
originating mastering application
projects
dataplex's lakes and zones give us an
elegant way to group our data assets
depending upon their type their quality
or their stage in their data life cycle
and we're experimenting with the designs
for operating this at an enterprise
level but these zones are a very
important concept for us
in fact we implemented something similar
uh in our on-premise data lake
however with dataplex we can take this
to the next level
realizing a much more federated system
employing a type of data mesh
architecture if you will where data
remains in situ owned and governed by
its originators yet still part of a
unified platform maintained by dataplex
and integrated with a set of leading
analytical tools
i think gcp's data catalog also gives us
amazing capabilities it gives us
visibility of key organizational data
assets but with dataplex we can go a
step further
and extend the data catalog with the
automated discovery and classification
of semi-structured and unstructured data
now ensuring our data is secure is of in
paramount importance and we're investing
heavily in the automation of controls
and embedding those controls into our
infrastructure
as code and as policies
however today we still need to develop
those controls for each data service we
use
we also need to find a way of enforcing
them through infrastructure as code
templates and tools such as terraform
this adds complexity
with dataplex we have the potential to
develop these controls once
for the lake zone and assets and let
dataplex do the hard work of applying
them to the different underlying
technologies
and the plans dataplex has for extending
this policy driven approach to include
data governance data management and data
quality tasks is particularly exciting
we can imagine a world where we assess
transform and promote our high quality
data based upon policies and not hand
coded data pipelines
allowing us to focus more on the value
creating tasks and less on maintaining
boilerplate data integration
so in summary i think we see bigquery
for analytics and dataplex for data
management
as cornerstones of our vision for
enabling a secure and frictionless data
experience in the cloud
well thank you john thank you for
sharing your insights and perspective
with us today
and also thank you for you and to you
and your team for your continued
partnership
um so as as you heard john just outlined
dataplex helps enterprises unlock
the free freedom of choice by providing
them the flexibility to keep data where
they see fit and to use the tools that
they need to run analysis within their
organization
dataplex provides a way to enable
consistent controls across enterprise
data landscape that is inherently
distributed
and finally with dataplex our customers
can leverage the built-in data
intelligence to automate many of the
common data tasks around data management
and governance across the data estate
so that's all that we have today
if you would like to learn more about
dataplex do check our website
and thank you everyone for your time
today and for attending this session
on
how dataplex helps enterprises break
down their data silos thanks again
thanks